[Música]
en mi primer trabajo después la
universidad tenía horario tenía que
estar antes de las ocho y media si no
estaba ese horario era todo un problema
mi trabajo consistía en llegar a
sentarme en una computadora a hacer
cosas y las reuniones volver a esa
computadora a hacer más cosas y demás
reuniones tal vez incluso más reuniones
volver a la computadora y hacer más
cosas de ocho y media a cinco y media de
ocho y media a cinco y media de ocho y
media a cinco y media y así todos los
días el trabajo por momento se sentía
estructurado casi asfixiante en el
tiempo que estuve ahí pensé muchísimo en
el significado el trabajo de ir al
trabajo
yo no sabía en ese momento que esa
frustración que sentía muchos años
después se iba a convertir en la empresa
que me tocó fundar hace 7 años creamos
work and a una plataforma de fe y la del
trabajo remoto y digital para mí fue un
momento increíble era empezar algo de
cero con gente que admiro crear un
equipo una cultura de empresa la verdad
que fue un sueño hecho realidad hoy la
plataforma está súper bien llegamos a 2
millones de freelancers se publican
alrededor de 30 mil proyectos todos los
meses estamos liderando américa latina y
lanzando en el sudeste asiático
pero creo que en ese momento no teníamos
idea a lo que nos estábamos sumando
decíamos que teníamos a todo el mundo le
contábamos que el mundo del trabajo
estaba cambiando pero no nos damos
cuenta que era tan grande que era el
cambio más grande que estaba teniendo en
los últimos 60 años es más creo que fue
hace tan sólo tres años estaba acá en
córdoba y un amigo mío invitó a almorzar
a la planta de una conocidísima marca de
gaseosas la verdad que tuvo bárbaro
porque era ir a dar la vuelta por la
planta me mostraron cómo se embotellaba
máquinas que yo no sabía ni tenida que
existían la verdad que si se acuerdan en
el colegio los que tuvimos oportunidad
de ir a una visita a la fábrica o mayor
el nene que está vaya adelante todo
haciendo preguntas supermercado
el tour terminada en el piso
administración y marketing donde
trabajaba mi amigo y ahí me asombro
continuo pero cambió bastante de tono al
frente mío de haber habido entre 40 y 50
puestos de trabajo en todos en
absolutamente en todos había una
computadora de escritorio sobre la mesa
la empresa no se da cuenta que ya podía
darle la oportunidad a toda esa gente de
trabajar de otra forma pero ni siquiera
le da todavía las herramientas para que
así fuera
yo sé que es difícil sumarse a esto
entender que el trabajo dejó de ser un
lugar donde vamos sino algo que hacemos
el trabajo a lo largo de la historia ya
se movió del lugar bueno al menos en las
revoluciones industriales recientes en
la primera y de la segunda el trabajo se
movió de las granjas a las fábricas en
la tercera se movió de las fábricas a
las oficinas bien está en la cuarta es
distinto porque el trabajo se mueve de
las oficinas a las personas
y es un cambio increíble porque la
variable distancia deja de tener valor
y tuve otra epifanía un poquito tiempo
después de que almorzó con mis amigos
era nosotros teníamos que salir a buscar
una persona para nuestro equipo un
project manager para nuestro equipo de
desarrollo era un equipo nuevo que se
está formando así que dijimos
necesitamos que esta persona esté en
nuestra oficina en buenos aires porque
que esté con los chicos así se forma la
cultura compañía de equipo y trabajan
juntos entre los currículos que nos
llegan había uno de córdoba bueno me
dije tal vez se quiera mudar como hice
yo hace 15 años muy buenos aires
hablo con esta persona y la verdad que
es una entrevista espectacular hablamos
de todo incluso el volver al futuro para
los más jóvenes que no sabe lo que son
tres películas tan increíbles vean las
cierro paréntesis
la verdad que había un solo problema
santi como se llama me dijo no me quiero
mover mis amigos están en córdoba mis
cosas están acá yo quiero quedarme acá
me puso en jaque hablé con mis socios
que también lo habían entrevistado y lo
debatimos un montón nos costaba mucho
porque realmente creíamos que había que
formar un equipo todos juntitos habían
muchos en la oficina y lo debatimos pero
llegamos a una conclusión que nos dimos
cuenta que lo importante era el trabajo
y no desde donde se haga la verdad que
era este injusto si quieren darle el
puesto a alguien que vivía cerca de
nuestra oficina porque la verdad que el
candidato que nos haya gustado era otro
hoy la compañía somos 80 personas un
poquito más en realidad entra gente
todas las semanas
el 50 por ciento más o menos están
totalmente remotos y eso es sin contar a
los freelancers que nos ayudan todo el
tiempo en tareas más esporádicas somos
una compañía híbrida tenemos oficinas
oficinas pero también tenemos gente que
está remota y es es difícil ser híbridos
pero hoy que ya lo somos ya está pero
cosas tan simples como comunicarse según
en complejas por ejemplo dejar de usar
el método oral para comunicar cosas y
crear que todo el mundo ya se enteró
entender que hay muchos medios para
decir las cosas ya sea un email ya sea
un sistema de chat
herramientas más nuevas de chat como es
la que es una herramienta más nueva o
cosas para distribuir tareas como asana
o tres lo que era herramientas que
usamos en el pasado nos permiten
trabajar a todos mejor como si
estuviéramos ahí juntitos pero también
tener conciencia que todos necesitamos
una buena conexión internet tener un
buen headset tener un micrófono para que
se nos escuche a todos y una cámara
porque también nos gusta vernos es lindo
verse
y otras cosas más importante todavía que
todos se sientan integrados estamos
lejos la cultura la compañía es súper
poderosa va a llegar aunque no vamos
nada incluso a los remotos pero tenemos
que hacerlo de manera más consciente
tenemos que darle oportunidades a todos
incluso los remotos compartir los
resultados de la compañía barquito se
sienten cerca y si podemos si es posible
y en algún momento vernos en vivo
traernos a todos y ponernos en el mismo
lugar para que nos sintamos para romper
esa pequeña barrera que existe hasta que
nos vemos y nos tocamos
pero bueno ya somos somos híbridos
es un orgullo para nosotros la verdad
pero también creo que nos da una pequeña
ventaja al ser así porque cuando hoy
salimos a buscar talento para nuestro
equipo
nos pasa algo muy distinto a la mayoría
de las compañías todos decimos que
queremos tener el mejor talento adentro
nuestra compañía que eso es lo que
queremos pero lamentablemente la mayoría
cuando salen a buscar están diciendo un
poquito implícitamente el mejor talento
que viva alrededor de 10 km de donde
esté nuestra oficina alrededor de eso no
sé qué talento hay pero yo quiero el
mejor de aire y nosotros cuando salimos
a buscar gente y gracias que pudimos
vivir este cambio tenemos un límite
muchísimo mayor de miles de kilómetros
hoy tenemos personas en 7 países américa
latina y en 10 países en total entonces
yo creo que esto ya llegó y que las
compañías que no entiendan esto se van a
dar cuenta que van a estar compitiendo a
nivel internacional por talento local
se espera que los los trabajadores
libres de la ocasión como también os
llaman lleguemos a hacer en el 2000 35
mil millones si mil millones en
finlandia que ató nos encanta hacer es
dar ejemplo de finlandia porque hay
hacen todo bien
en tailandia de regular en el trabajo
flexible hace un montón uno puede elegir
con bastante libertad quiere llevar el
trabajo y también hay que reírse también
regular en el trabajo remoto ahora
estando el trabajo remoto uno va por
decidir la mitad de su tiempo desde
donde trabajar
claramente esto ya llegué hoy yo creo
que no es el resultado solamente del
avance tecnológico o del capricho de
nosotros los millennials sí me considero
millennial todavía sino que creo que
viene a responder preguntas mucho más
profundas sobre nosotros
por ejemplo ustedes
vos te pusiste a pensar que es tu
trabajo para vos
y para vos es tu trabajo
y al de arriba
cuando sacan lo mejor de ustedes
es el trabajo o en donde en donde sacan
en una actividad productiva donde sale
lo mejor de la mejor versión de ustedes
es el lugar de trabajo
o tal vez más profundo que eso no
como queremos vivir
yo creo que el trabajo tiene que tener
un alto grado de libertad porque si no
tenemos libertad nuestro trabajo si no
tenemos autonomía en lo que hacemos como
podemos esperar lo mejor de nosotros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]